here we are in a 2021 jeep renegade
proximity
got our radio frequency hub right here
above the headliner we're plugged into
it with our 2012 cable
as you can see
a plug plugged in here plugged into the
radio frequency hub
go ahead and connect
hazards are on
all right so let's read the pin
just so you guys know
to be connected to the internet it is
connected as you can see up here
it does take three tokens um
processing the pin and then two to
process the pin and then one to program
will store this info from my
understanding so if you ever have to do
it again it's just one token to program
[Music]
all right so we processed the pin
so now we're just going to add procs
there's our stored pen
yes
all right we'll walk up here and see
i think it just went through
there we are
that one just went through we're gonna
hit now
okay
disconnect
as you guys can hear it i'm gonna go
ahead and shut the hazards off
let me go ahead and connect the radio
frequency hub and be right back to start
it all right guys so as you can see we
just put
all the trim back here
all the rubber just kind of flips up
there's a snap about
right here and right here
but
you see a couple of creases but they'll
iron out so
all right back in it right now
foxes
sorry we're kind of undercover here it's
a rainy day prox is right here on the
seat
and we'll go ahead and start it
there we are
2021 jeep renegade uh this also works on
the 2021 compass as well
you